meet jenny lee
my name is jenny and i lobbied for the
dumpling takeout box fortune cookie and
chopsticks emojis
and this is the story of how jenny is
getting us four new emoji like it just
felt to me like there should be a
dumpling emoji and like while we're at
it we should add the takeout box fortune
cookie and chopsticks as of 2017 they're
coming to a keyboard near you
jenny was on an emoji crusade
you see in order to pitch an emoji you
have to infiltrate this worldwide
consortium named unicode you get very
quickly to the unicode consortium which
is a non-profit organization which
basically oversees emoji they're the
people who control the alphabet of your
emoji keyboard it has 11 full voting
members they pay 18 000 a year to like
have a full vote unicode sets the
standard and parameters around emoji you
see there are a set of rules all emoji
must abide by
there are no brands no deities and no
celebrities and when we hear about quote
kimoji those are not real accepted emoji
those are sort of like rogue emoji that
are really stickers so jenny started to
attend meetings for a swift 75 bucks
anyone can attend the meeting as a
non-voting member and you basically like
feel very welcome and so it feels a lot
like going to a new church
back to the dumpling what i did was you
know write a whole proposal about why
the dumpling deserved his own emoji
especially since it's so universal and
what's kind of cool is that like not
only is it a dumpling emoji it can be a
pierogi emoji or an empanada emoji got
that passed as a candidate emoji in
january of this year seems like a lot of
work for fun symbols no i was actually
much faster than i thought oh okay i
think it's really interesting to watch
the emoji
evolve
and that my friends is how an emoji is
born